hey everyone i'm ella valencia  today i am super excited to finally  announce that i play the lead character  frey  in working title project atheia a brand  new ip from square enix and luminous  productions  about a young woman in a beautiful yet  threatening world  the development team has been working  super super hard to create this  remarkable journey  and it's been incredibly exciting to be  a part of it frey is a character i  immediately connected with when this  project was first brought to me and i've  had  so much fun working with the team to  bring her character to life  in performance capture and voice  recording sessions  while we're not quite ready to reveal  everything today  we do have a sneak peek at a brand new  scene from the game  and the final name to share so please  enjoy  hide is that a [ __ ] dragon  is it gone yes and we should leave this  place as well why that thing out there  [Music]  you